inspiring today's draft is taysom hill's
unique skill set the best gimmick
players in nfl history chris you've got
a question for me if i get it right i
get the first pick and my first pick
will not be taysom hill by the way i i i
hope not you know i mean you know for
the spirit of the draft that should not
be your first pick it should be against
the rules in fact we should be able to
pick him in general right now i think
all together but either way
the taysom hill memorial draft i think i
think that's what we do whenever we take
a guy out all right it's the jason hill
memorial draft even though he's still
alive go ahead all right cool good all
right i like that we got enough options
all right who has the longest run
by a quarterback
in nfl history
who has
lost
90 yards tyrell prior nine raiders
93 yards but good job man that was
really i'm impressed way to go all right
you know who was against i could still
remember it against the jets and the
meadowlands i think i believe that was
the day it happened maybe i'm wrong i
just remember i could be wrong i don't
know i thought it was at home i thought
it was home you might be right i think
it is at home now that i'm thinking
about it
he ran through that crappy infield that
we'll never have to see again okay um it
was against the steelers pete demolitis
says all right there we go this one's
easy the all-time gimmick player uh one
of the cornerstone members of the
chicago bears of 1985 he took not just
the football world by storm he was a
crossover cultural icon william the
refrigerator perry all 300 plus pounds
of him he's a guy who looked like he was
500 pounds even though he wasn't much
over 300 pounds back in those days there
weren't as many 300 pounders but running
the ball out of the backfield i think he
caught a pass at one point in a monday
night football game against the packers
but but it captured the imagination of
people beyond the normal football fan it
was it was a dream come true for the nfl
in the mid 80s because it got those
casual super bowl fans engaged in the 85
bears weeks before they otherwise would
have been paying attention because
everybody was talking about william the
refrigerator perry the all-time great
nfl gimmick player chris
yeah that's that's tough to go against i
mean it really is uh that's the guy that
i wanted to pick first that's why i was
mad you got that question right there
but either way that's that's kind of
where it started right i mean that was
the first guy that i
when i was growing up watching football
that was really played out of position
in an interesting way in a gimmicky type
of way either way and uh you know that
it was cool it really was and we're
seeing it a little now right i think the
the bears akeem hicks they got him doing
a little bit of that the last few years
playing fullback for them
he scored the uh he scored the touchdown
in super bowl 20 that should have gone
to walter payton and that's spike he
like he he cranked up for it two or
three times and it was not a spike he
threw the ball out of the screen i don't
know if it ever even hit the ground uh
but uh the the the fridge the fridge was
you know it was one of those years and
every year there's some theme that pops
up and there's something that makes it
unique and special from every other year
in 85 it was the bears and it was
refrigerator perry and and
in many respects there's been nothing
else like it since then all right you're
off no no that was a team with great
personalities all right i'm going to
slash all right i mean slash when i was
you know in high school cordell stewart
pittsburgh steelers
hadn't seen anything like that what this
college quarterback's playing receiver
he's playing running back he's playing
quarterback sometimes they're trying to
groom him into the future quarterback
whatever it may be
i mean hey he's a guy he was a big part
of that super bowl team that lost to the
cowboys in super bowl xxx there because
of his ability to do those slash-type
plays you know so he was the first guy i
really remember you know on that side of
the ball that started doing multiple
things on the offense you know
that vast you know difference as far as
running back receiver i think he even
did some punting too if i remember
correctly so there really wasn't
anything cordell stewart couldn't do
he's a phenomenal athlete he was a big
part of that pittsburgh steelers
organization for for a big chunk in time
and and certainly made some plays in his
time there
and you know what at one level
he
he he kind of proves my point as to
taysom hill
that a guy who does a bunch of things
before he becomes a starting quarterback
can still be a great starting
quarterback but i i i don't know how
great cordell stewart was you know he
had moments in his career and i think
with him
it was a very gradual building of his
confidence and it was something that
happened slowly and surely and then
something that would happen that would
shatter his confidence and he would be
back down in the valley again and you'd
have to build it up slowly he went
through that two or three times during
his time as a starter chris and uh
really until they turned the page on him
and went with tommy maddox in 2002 the
steelers gave it a good three or four
years before they they decided he
couldn't be the guy remember he ended up
in chicago for a little while and then
kind of washed out of the league but he
had his chance and uh yeah it was
special 1995 slash that was uh that was
again like like the fridge 10 years
earlier a guy who took the nfl by storm
all right next one for me
and uh this really
was a gimmick
it was the start of something that that
became a trend in the nfl for a few
years and it was something born out of
desperation the 2008 miami dolphins
after a couple of games could not move
the football they were desperate to come
up with ways to move the football and on
the way home from their their loss in
week two they had a conversation i think
it was david lee the former college
coach
said let's do the wildcat and they had a
conversation with the offensive players
and uh they they asked the the
non-quarterbacks anybody uh uh having a
history throwing the football want to
try to run quarterback in this thing and
ronnie brown put his hand up and the
rest is history because they went into
new england the following week and they
obliterated the patriots on their own
floor in their own building 38-13
ronnie brown ran rough shot over the
patriots he had
four touchdown rushes that day and a
touchdown pass to anthony fasano five
total touchdowns from ronnie brown in
the birth of the wildcat even though the
wildcat dates back years earlier they
brought it back it became a thing in the
nfl for several years after that it
still shows up in the madden playbooks
even though nobody really uses it
anymore but ronnie brown even though it
didn't last long it burned very brightly
and on that day in september of 2008 the
the patriots got burned by big time yeah
well it was the first time we had seen a
team i feel like go all in on it a
little bit like you're right we had seen
it before then but that was the first
game where we went like damn there's
like a full game plan of this stuff this
is unreal and we are still seeing it
mike you know hey whether it's taste
some hill or you know hey think about
travis kelsey he lined up a quarterback
in the super bowl and ran for a first
down in the wildcat you know i think he
did that two different times so it is
become a little bit of a you know a
wrinkle aspect of every good play
callers play sheet to where they have a
few plays like that greatest great
schematical advantage you know as far as
getting that having one extra blocker in
the run game that really
puts a defense in a tough spot so
that was that was unbelievable i can
still remember seeing that going wow you
know belichick and the the patriots are
flustered they don't know what hit them
okay
um
dion sanders will be my next pick
yes dion sanders i don't care that he
was the best corner to ever play
football he also had a gimmick aspect to
him i mean yeah kick returner punt
returner we know that but
dude could play somebody though wait a
minute i'm throwing a challenge flag
don't gimmick it's not a gimmick game
just pick the guy that played running
nothing else be quiet you just picked
the guy that played running back and
nothing but he was quarterback he was
quarterbacking
i mean deon sanders probably had as many
throws as he did in the career so relax
hold on because he also played receiver
all right he played receiver a lot he's
got play i think he played receiver so
much you can't call it a gimmick he
caught 36 passes in 1996 that's not a
gimmick that that's a that's a part-time
job at that point no no it's a gimmick
that's what it is you're mad that i
picked them and it's a great pick by me
and they put them in there to run
reverses and deep balls and he caught a
bomb in super bowl 30 from troy aikman
and i can still remember sitting there
watching that so hey whatever you want
to say i mean the guy had versatility
and you could use them in gimmicky type
ways you jerk okay he's far more
gimmicky than ronnie brown so deal with
it
he had 36 catches for 475 yards in 1996.
by far that was his biggest output the
rest of his career it was more sporadic
and he didn't do much more gimmick by
way of playing receiver after yeah
i'm looking for any he did throw two
career passes one with the falcons one
with the cowboys both were incomplete so
that would make his passer rating 39.6
if you throw an incomplete pass no
interceptions no yardage gained 39.6 is
your rating all right next one for me
hmm
hmm
i i guess i gotta go mike verbal i gotta
go mike vrabel because when i think of
the patriots in their first iteration
when they won three super bowls in four
years and and one of the one of the
images of mike frable catching a
touchdown pass in a super bowl game is
actually on the cover of the nfl record
and fact book which only me peter king
and chris magdawg rousseau now possess
every year but uh vrabel the linebacker
and he caught so many touchdown passes
you almost have to argue it wasn't a
gimmick anymore but um he he he uh he
had plenty of work catching touchdown
passes from tom brady especially in big
moments chris what was the natural you
know like looked like a tight end moved
like a tight end caught the ball
effortlessly yeah and it just seemed
like in playoff football and super bowls
you always had to be worried about mike
grebel
they were going to find a way to give
him the ball so
i'm with you that was a guy that was on
my list certainly and uh yeah i mean
he's he's more than a you know gimmicky
guy can catch tight end you know catch
passes tackles people can coach teams
holy cow he's got it all going he's very
talented individual there um you know
i'm
i don't know what i guess
ultimately here all right i wanted to
pick somebody from the modern day like
right now but how can i not pick george
blanda i mean george bland as a guy like
i never even saw highlights of
and even before i was even aware of who
he was as a young kid i remember people
talking about oh george blender he can
kick it and throw it and do everything
for your football team i mean george
blanda his statistics you know i mean
it's
98 or 99
extra point kicker
above 50 field goal kicker let alone
being a really damn good quarterback to
go along with that uh i don't know that
to me is a special skill set right there
so i'm dropping the challenge flag again
no no you eat that one you're picking a
guy from an era where they played both
ways they did everything they had 15
guys on the team so not everybody's a
gimmick that's just the way it was
no they weren't and either way it
doesn't take away from his vast skill
set so
uh eat it i don't like you
you should have taken uh doug flutie for
his dropkick
uh that that would have been my next one
if there was another round or if you had
taken all mine the the remember the
dropkick for doug flutie for the extra
point i do that counts
i didn't know if that classified as
enough gimmick for you mr lawyer so i
didn't want to pick that
we're running out of time we got more
pfd live coming at you right after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports